-Welcome back, everybody.
Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs
and we especially love songs
written by our audience members
in under an hour.
It's time for "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Singing a song,
and I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Before the show, we went through
our audience and picked out
two people who said that
they were musicians.
We gave them each a made-up
song title and gave them an hour
to write an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
This is real. Yeah.
Let's see what they came up with
and meet them right now.
Come on over, guys.
Welcome.
Hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you.
-Nice to see you.
-Hi. Welcome. Nice to see you.
-Hi. Thank you.
-Welcome to the show.
Let's start
with contestant number one.
What is your name and where
are you from?
-My name is Miranda.
I'm from Dallas, Texas.
-Hey! We love Dallas, Texas.
Big Dallas, Texas fan. Yeah.
Welcome to the show.
What title were you given?
What title of the song?
-"Sweater Weather Love Letter."
-Ooh!
So we kind of gave you
a rhyme already.
Yeah, made it
real easy for you. Yeah.
"A Sweater Weather"...
"Sweater Weather Love Letter."
-"Love Letter."
-Yeah, perfect.
And what instrument
will you be playing tonight?
-Piano.
-Oh, beautiful.
Alright, go up and get ready
and get in your headspace.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This will be exciting here.
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere
of the soon-to-be classic
"Sweater Weather Love Letter,"
it's Miranda Contreras-Peterson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I take myself to town ♪
♪ And I take a look around ♪
♪ Oh, the leaves have
all changed ♪
♪ Like flames before my eyes ♪
Thank you.
♪ This is an ode to autumn ♪
♪ A nod to fall ♪
♪ A song for my coat
that hangs on the wall ♪
♪ And the candles I light
to brighten the halls ♪
♪ It's a sweater-weather
love letter ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ It's a poem for my heart
that keeps me warm ♪
♪ Until I get to go back home ♪
♪ Like birds of a feather,
we will flock together ♪
♪ And share
our stories and our sweaters ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoo-whoo!
-Thank you.
-Ooh, I love that!
Give it up for Miranda,
everybody.
That was incredible.
Whoo! Let's meet
contestant number two.
What is your name and
where are you from?
-My name is Oren Levin, and I'm
from Ann Arbor, Michigan.
-Hey, Oren!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ann Arbor. Shout-out
to Ann Arbor, Michigan.
Alright, Oren, tell everyone
what your song title is.
-My song title
was very different.
It was "Cranberry Sauce
Isn't a Sauce."
-What instrument
are you playing?
-I'm playing the guitar.
The acoustic guitar.
-Alright, buddy. Oren, go over
and get the guitar on,
and I'll introduce you.
Come over here, Miranda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen, get ready
for the world premiere of
"Cranberry Sauce Isn't Even
a Sauce" by Oren Levin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Now, I'm a lover of sauces ♪
♪ Mustard, pesto, no conflict ♪
♪ A.1. or glaze from a pen ♪
♪ But with Thanksgiving
coming up ♪
♪ There's just one
heinous enough ♪
♪ To come right out of a can ♪
♪ I know it takes some time
to chew turkey that's dry ♪
♪ But I'd rather dip it in ranch
than use a lump ♪
♪ What is that stuff? ♪
♪ Don't know what to call it ♪
♪ But sauce,
it shouldn't be solid.
♪ Oh, cranberry sauce
isn't even a sauce ♪
♪ Yeah, cranberry sauce
♪ It's shaped like a can ♪
♪ It comes out of a tube ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, cranberry sauce ♪
♪ Yeah, I know that
I'm screwed ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm a saucy dude ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Get over here! Come on!
-Saucy dude.
-He's a saucy dude.
Not bad. That was a good setup.
There you go.
Give it up
for Oren once again.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, now we're
going to see who won.
We're going to let our great
audience decide the winner.
Yes. Was it Miranda?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Oren?
We're going to give it to Oren.
Congratulations.
Oren is the winner.
You get -- Congratulations.
You get this
"I love music" sweatshirt.
Congratulations.
-I do love music.
-Yes, and that's for you.
-Amazing!
You also get a "Tonight Show"
notebook for writing more songs.
And you get $1,000, as well.
Thank you. Congratulations.
-Appreciate it.
-But no one goes home
empty-handed.
Our other contestant
will receive an
"I love music" sweatshirt,
as well.
-I do! Awesome.
-And a "Tonight Show" notebook
and a $1,000.
-Oh!
-There you go.
-Oh! Everybody's a winner.
-Yes. Give it up for your new
instant songwriters.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Jared Leto!
Come on back, everybody!
Well done.